the thing with entrepreneurship is we
all saw what happened a couple years ago
you know with a scam demic where they
said wear this phas diaper stand on this
dot oh by the way it's time for you to
take our experimental uh jab we're not
sure if it's going to work but we're
pretty sure it's safe and effective you
know three months into building this
thing out and I had a lot of people at
that time that were like look man been
watching your stuff I understand your
views and your take I'm I'm in the same
you know Camp as you but if I don't take
this thing I'm going to lose my job and
I have a mortgage to pay and you know
like a wife and children to take care of
in my house so what do I do and the vast
majority of these guys that didn't have
options that were a slave to the
corporate grind it didn't matter if it
was seite jobs it didn't matter if it
was a licensed professional that was
working in a hospital and an accounting
firm in a financial instrument type of
office type thing it didn't matter any
of those things if the Mandate existed
and it came down from corporate down the
ladder you know sort of thing then you
had to do it you could have been making
you know5 $600,000 a year making great
money for a company then all of a sudden
they said oh by the way you need to do
this okay and that's not something that
exists in the realm of Entrepreneurship
you don't have that obligation you know
um in fact a lot of friends of mine that
run companies they didn't even mandate
anything because it was just a
recommendation and it's only like these
large Corps that and they're in bed with
the government okay I mean I've talked
before about my lobbying efforts and the
collusion between uh government
financial institutions and how they work
together very clearly to their interests
you know a lot of people think oh the
government's all there to take care of
us and look after us and all of those
things and it's like dive a little
deeper down the rabbit hole my friend
there's something to learn there there's
a lot more going on than what you think
so back to the notion of the
entrepreneurship you have that flexible
flexibility and freedom let me tell you
a story about my buddy Adrian
so he was living in Ottawa a few years
ago when this thing kicked
off and he had a facility in uh the
states and his partner worked down there
and he worked up in Canada they you know
they met up uh you know once a month and
did their thing and then he started
seeing what was happening with mandates
standing on dots wearing face diapers
and then what was coming over the
horizon after that which was going to be
take our experimental uh Jabba juice
and he said 'y you know what I'm out he
sold everything he had a location
Independent Business that he could run
from anywhere in the world that didn't
rely on a storefront an OP a neon open
sign or any of that any of those things
packed his bags sold his G wagon sold
his condo took his girlfriend dogs they
went down south and they started
investing in Mexican real estate they've
been doing quite well um when you have
your life structured in such a way that
you don't have to become an obedient
compliant hey jump okay Master how high
right when you've got your life
structured in such a way where you've
got mobility and you've got freedom to
maneuver and you can act on
it that's something to be said and you
can make a lot of money too um there's
no I mean I don't like to emphasize the
notion of get rich quick but there's no
more rapid path rout rout to financial
success and growth and Entrepreneurship
I think I still have it down here
actually yeah I
do it was
um what's the date on this so this is
January 19th
2009 and I Incorporated my business the
debt relief business that I started up
in the early 2000s uh five years before
this and this wasn't the first time that
we got recognized for
hypergrowth right so you I mean it's
going to be hard for you to see the date
on that but you can see this is the
business section of the Toronto Star and
that's me over there and the headline is
saving people drowning in a sea of debt
that was in our old office in um
Markham and that was the third time that
the company got awarded for hypergrowth
which meant we were doing over 100%
growth year-over-year
so without emphasizing too much the
rapid path to making a lot of money and
generating a lot of receivables and
sales receipts and if you set it up
correctly profit as well without banging
on that drum too much it's part and
parcel of the process right if you if
you set up the foundation correctly you
can build rapidly on top of that and I
wasn't even the fastest growing company
like I think on the profit uh 50 I was
somewhere in the middle on the 150 I was
like two-thirds of the way up so there
was a lot of other companies that were
growing way faster than I was in the
same time frame because it's all based
on time frame right and they and they
validate it with um your audited uh
books um your reconciled books you know
from the year before so it's accurate um
they're all private companies so they
don't publish uh profits but what they
were publishing was the uh sales
receipts so yeah is it a rapid path it
is absolutely I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out